Speaker 1: we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David, P. I am hoping.
That today we are closing the books on the
Me Leaving the Country saga.
I was asked if you left the country because
things got bad, where would you go?
And so I gave an answer.
And then I was told, You're abandoning us,
you're not a team player.
I'm canceling my membership because I can't
support someone who would just leave if things
got bad.
And I had to say, No, no, no, guys, I'm not
planning on leaving.
I'm not planning on leaving.
I was asked if you were to leave, where would
you go?
And then I was told, Oh, but you sound like
a Jew traitor, Jews who take their capital
elsewhere.
OK, let's hope that this voicemail is the
final note on this entire leaving the country
thing
Speaker 6: to those people, to all those people
that you say who contacted you via email.
Yes, we let you know very dismay, anger, disgust,
the threatening to actually cancel your membership
because they consider to be some kind of a
traitor, some kind of a Jew traitor.
Oh, banning, abandoning us, feigning, abandoning
your country, blah blah blah.
At least half of those people would do the
very same thing if they were able to.
I think a lot of those people who express
negative thoughts towards you and email are
the people who can't leave.
You're not able to leave.
You don't have the wherewithal that maybe
they're angry and resent that.
So there's that.
I think you address the question quite well
towards the end.
Oh, you don't need to apologize any any normal
person if faced with extreme circumstances
externally in his or her own country, would
it such as human nature survival, desperate
people do desperate things.
It's not a question of being loyal or patriotic.
Dad, we're a nation of strangers.
If any country was a country, a nation of
strangers as the United States, because the
last thing we are is united.
So don't let them trouble you.
I hope you can make up any revenue.
You might have lost those nukes hotels because
they can't do what you do.
They have to be they have to be to engage
in retribution in spite of them.
I'm in the horse they rode in on while you
do what you have to do.
And by the way, that's not to say you can't
continue your show that you know that you
can't broadcast to people in America from
a different country technology.
Because to do that, yeah,
Speaker 1: not only that, I've done it and
there have been there have been stretches
of time where I've been out of the U.S. and
the beep I missed, I didn't announce it because
there was no reason to announce it, but nobody
had any idea.
So I don't think it's not really a question
of being able to do the show.
So let's hope that that's the final note on
this leaving the country.
I have no plan to leave the country.
We will talk on today's bonus show about the
resignation of CNN's president over a consensual
relationship with an employee.
We will talk about a push to make the Lunar
New Year a federal holiday.
And we will we will actually talk about jury
deliberations in the Roy Moore defamation
case.
Remember, this is the bonus show much maligned
by Alex Jones.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is
Speaker 1: bad, right?
What an endorsement.
And I invite you to sign up at join Packman
dot com.
You'll get instant access and I will see you
on the bonus show momentarily.